Leslie I typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems the band
has had a few different names over the
years we started we were teddy bear
suicide but then we changed it to mouse
rat uh then we were God hates figs two
doors down Department of Homeland
obscurity then we were three skin just
the tip Flames for Flames muscle
confusion nothing rhymes with orange
then everything rhymes with orange Andy
Dwyer experience A.D and the d-bags the
Andy Andy Andy's radwagon five skin
foreskin nothing rhymes with blue orange
death of a scam artist razor dick puppy
pendulum awesome pendulum penis pendulum
and real suicide Angel snack
uh jet black pope punch face Champions
ninja dick we went back to mouse rat and
now we are Scarborough boat
when I hear myself say scarecrow boat
out loud I kind of hate it
every time I cleanse I can literally
feel the toxins leaving my body I know I
feel so much healthier I forgot a full
week to go before the broth stage
pre-broth is an amazing stage it's when
you're most alert good
someone needs to be alert tonight this
poison
like an elephant okay if I walk into a
room it's like okay he's in there
turn this music down
[Music]
baby I'm back thank you so wow oh why
are you naked oh well because of what
you said we're getting back together no
we're not yes we are you should have
heard the super sexy stuff she was
saying to me I said hey Andy it's Ann
can we talk at my house you said it you
were like hey Andy it's Ann can you
at my house oh my God you're such a baby
oh literally big naked baby put clothes
on
you know what
I should have seen this coming yeah I
love cupcakes Alice hates you Annie has
herpes
problem my problem is you smell us Ben
told you to finish the website and if
you don't do it I swear to God I'm gonna
murder you in your sleep I know where
you live 14th Street right I'm gonna get
a melon baller and scoop your eyes out
spent uncle's gonna have to buy you a
dog to drag your eyeless face around
yes
do it okay
let's give the sucker a test drive
yeah so the idea is to make a fountain
that he can't do that to
you that's good okay any ideas Jerry
well I was thinking that we could put
this cage thing around it okay that
could work Andy
thank you Andy
still good top full disclosure Ann and I
are romantically intertwined oh god so
let's not be surprised if she fixed my
idea would you just go dummy what's the
best kind of water fountain
how about no water fountain
is the Voss water Butler by Toomey at
only six hundred dollars a bag April
what's your idea to go in that room and
finish this book oh really yeah is it
good yeah
we're gonna stay here and you're gonna
help
Donna do I look like I drink water why
do I want to build this park so bad
maybe because a pit filled with garbage
isn't the best that we can do in America
you know in Russia they could pretend
that pit was a park
bring their kids down there
hey Vlad uh look at these rocks let's
pretend they're potatoes Nikolai do you
want to swim in the dirt
but not here
okay because we're a nation to dreamers
and it is my dream to build a park
that I one day visit with my White House
staff on my birthday
and they say president nope
this park is awesome
now we understand why you are the first
female president of the United States
I vomited somewhere in this room
I don't remember where though
wait you might want to check that drawer
stop
pooping
you have to get up off the floor now as
far as my friend
I can't get through to the cable company
can I do something like one based on
truth
anything Andy's just acting out scenes
from his favorite movies
Swayze runs boom tackles the guy off the
motorcycle dude's like your dad bro
comes Adam Swayze Ducks scissor kick the
guy has sweets his head and he says I
used to guys like you in prison by the
looks of this guy this is not consensual
sex we're talking about we see bad guy
had a gun the whole time he's like I
so he's like not this time that subtext
he doesn't say that bypasses the gun
hooks the arm back to the secret move he
used before to kill somebody he feels so
bad about it but this time he has to do
it because self-defense
takes the esophagus out of the neck area
you can't eat you'll starve to death and
that his Roadhouse what should I do next
you guys uh
know anything about a guy named John
Rambo open on villagers being thrown out
into a rice field landmines blowing them
up into pieces and that's how it ends
I loved it it's called babe
and I know it sounds corny talking pig
whatever you should all see it
I just did
scrawny Christians missionaries come to
him and they're like are you John Rambo
he's like yeah no like we need you to
take us up River he's like it's a war
zone up there and they're like yeah we
know we're gonna change things
and he's like
you booger to do weapons they're like of
course not they do not change anything
go home and then they come back in a
rainstorm this time he says
nope go home say go home again bottom
line they go up River does not go well
the floor is now open for public
comments oh here we go thank you my name
is Garth blunden and I object to your
ridiculous proposal uh the Pawnee
Charter uh shall not be changed not
today not ever wow a lot of passion Mr
blundin thank you so much your objection
is noted and officially in the record
shall we proceed no no we shall not
article 7 section 3 allows for a citizen
filibuster if I stand here and refuse to
yield my time you are prohibited from
voting on the bill
that section defines buffalo meat as
acceptable currency is that the buffalo
meat one
I meant article 3 section seven
let the filibustering begin I would now
like to share some ideas I have for JJ
Abrams seventh chapter in the Star Wars
saga pan down from the Twin sons of
Tatooine we are now close on the mouth
of the sarlacc pit after a beat the
gloved Mandalorian armor Gauntlet of
Boba Fett grabs onto the sand outside
the sarlacc pit and the feared Bounty
Hunter pulls himself from the maw of the
sand Beast then he's right he can do
this this is exactly why we need to
modernize these laws this kind of thing
made sense when we had counsel in a barn
and there were 80 people in the town but
now this is nuts if he holds the reality
gem that means he can jump from
different realities this will be our
link to the Marvel Universe from the
Star Wars Universe imagine those two
going up against robot Chewbacca because
that's going to happen after a beat Luke
says Darth Vader was my father but Ben
Kenobi was my master and he cuts
Hannibal Lecter in half Mr blundin
I'm sorry are you leaving I thought we
had a meeting no we do it's just I think
it's a little chilly in here are you
okay your eyes are glassy oh my God oh
my is she is she sick are you sick no
yeah she's sick
that's why I'm wearing this and misting
myself with hand sanitizer I'm not sick
I just have allergies okay I took a
Claritin and I threw that up so I took
another one I threw that up and then I
took a third and it stayed down I'm
getting better all right you're burning
up you're burning up what I have to get
out of here I have 2.8 body fat my
body's like a microchip a grain of sand
could destroy it
my butt is microchip
leslaco no I can't I can't go home I
have to get ready for the Chamber of
Secrets Commerce if this meeting does
not go perfectly then the Harvest
Festival is going to be over before it
begin I cannot go home okay then who's
your doctor
Ann's my doctor
and she's the most beautiful nurse in
the world come on oh God no I'm hot now
it's really hot in here okay well that's
your fever Leslie I typed your symptoms
into the thing up here and it says you
could have network connectivity problems
all right